the waiting has finally come to an end
as on Wednesday Warner Brothers
announced the release date of the Batman
for June 2021 and innovation will also
cause some surprises because as we
already suspected in one of our early
Kino tech news episodes Ben Affleck will
no longer be seen as Batman in front of
the camera according to director Matt
Reeves the main reason was that they
were looking for a younger leading actor
this also fits in with the statement he
made in a recent interview with thr
Reeves had planned something the fans
have never seen before
the storyline is supposed to revolve
around Batman's exciting but also
emotional life story
another novelty will be that the
action-packed parks we have seen in the
past movies will be abandoned in order
to concentrate on Batman's detective
skills which have not yet been really
focused on in the films the question
which will and Batman has to deal with
is not really answered in detail the
only thing we know yet is that he's
going to have to deal with more than
just one opponent even though the
release in the summer of 2021 is still a
long way off in the end we can expect a
Batman movie that has been worked out
down to the last detail margot robbie
gave us on instagram a first glimpse of
her role as harley quinn in the upcoming
DC film birds of prey in contrast to her
gloomy appearance in the 2016 Suicide
Squad
she looks rather colorful and playful in
this picture in addition we see the main
characters and their costumes in the new
teaser Rabi dances in her mentioned
outfit amused with a drink in her hand
and also her gang can be seen among them
Helena Bertinelli as Huntress Dinah
lands as Black Canary Gotham City police
woman Renny Montoya and Cassandra Cain
the collective will fight against black
mask and antagonist of Batman who hasn't
been seen in the movies before after all
there are still just few informations
about birds of prey let alone a trailer
the film co-produced by Margot Robbie
will be released in less than a year
namely on February 7th 2020 last week in
an MTV interview drained the rock
Johnson confirmed he will not be a part
in Fast and Furious 9 a big shock for
all
fans after all fan favorite The Rock has
been involved in every part since Fast
Five and has played a not inconsiderable
part in the Fast & Furious series
breakthrough revenues Iraq has his hands
full with the upcoming Fast and Furious
spin-off Hobson Sean as you can see in
several Instagram posts more our WWE
star Roman reigns and American football
player Josh Maga will also be part of
HAP's crew while action star Jason
Statham will be seen on the opposite
side future preparations for the release
of Hopson shown on August 1st 2019
Johnson says there's no free space in
the schedule for Fast and Furious 9qu
the relief of some fans however he adds
that it's not unlikely that you will get
back in the game after the ninth part
after all there is also the one or other
unsettled difference between Johnson's
character Hobbs
and done played by win diesel our fans
all over the world will be disappointed
the great reboot planned for this summer
and already finished shooting will be
postponed by half a year and that
usually means nothing good because if it
already filmed movies postponed it is
usually due to dissatisfaction on the
part of the producers and which results
in reshoots
and not on possibilities that the first
weekend of the new year for horror films
usually brings a successful cinema star
most recently seen at Sony's escape room
the content of the reboot is supposed to
be full of even more sinister ghosts
which this time doesn't include Toshio
and KOCO by the way nevertheless there
will be some familiar faces to see
including the nonstop Debian each year
Lin Shia from insidious and William
sever from Shawshank Redemption and also
with director Nicholas passion he seemed
to have found a capable man for horror
movie which is not supposed to become
mainstream at all so whether the release
postponement to January 3rd 2020 was the
right decision or not we will be able to
see with our own eyes next year as we
reported in the past Warner Brothers
could win over the from Disney fired
screenwriter and director James Gunn to
continuous kills in the DC Universe his
first project The Suicide Squad has now
released said the sake of August 2021
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
Suicide Squad won't
a direct successor of the hardy heart
first part but will contain a different
story as well as other main characters
James can who already has experience
with top-class movies as the former
director of guardians of the galaxy will
have a free hand in the design whether
we will see Harlequin that Chuck kept
boomerang killer croc or maybe even the
Joker in the cinema is still uncertain
but the guest appearance is not unlikely
we are definitely looking forward to
more news from the DC Universe after all
2021 already seems to be a good year for
film fans with the Batman and the
Suicide Squad
[Music]